RESTORATION WORK IS NOT LIKELY
TO BEGIN UNTIL 2021.
BACK IN THE U.S., THE PARTISAN
LINES IN WASHINGTON ARE CLEAR
FOR THE WORLD TO SEE.
ONE SURPRISING PLACE WHERE SOME
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ARE ON
THE SAME SIDE IS OVER AMERICA'S
PAST TIME.
ANYWAY --
>> WOW.
TOO SOON.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO
SAVE, ESSENTIALLY, MINOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
>> OKAY, SO MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL HAS ABOUT 150 MINOR
LEAGUE TEAMS.
WHAT MINOR-LEAGUE BASEBALL WANTS
TO DO IS SHUT OFF THE BOTTOM 40.
I'M SORRY.
BOTTOM 40.
THESE ARE THE APPELLATION
LEAGUES.
THIS IS TRAINING LEAGUES.
THIS IS THE NEW YORK
PENNSYLVANIA LEAGUE.
THESE ARE SINGLE-A AND BELOW.
THEY WANT TO SHOVE THOSE OFF
INTO SOMETHING ELSE SO THAT THEY
CAN FOCUS ON THE CORE BUSINESS
OF THE HUNDRED 20 OR SO
REMAINING PEOPLE.
IF YOU LIVE IN A TOWN WHERE ONE
OF THOSE SMALLER TEAMS ARE,
YOU'RE PROBABLY UPSET.
>> Bret: SO, THERE'S A
BIPARTISAN LETTER TO THE
COMMISSIONER IN WHICH IT SAYS,
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
MINOR-LEAGUE CLUBS IS NOT IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE OVERALL
GAME OF BASEBALL, ESPECIALLY
WHEN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL'S
REVENUES ARE AT AN ALL-TIME
HIGH.
THOSE REVENUES INCLUDE
$1.2 BILLION IN PROFITS IN 2019
AND FROM MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THE QUESTION IS FOR PEOPLE LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS AND OTHERS, IS
THIS AN ISSUE TO CAMPAIGN ON?
>> I'M SURE HE WISHES THAT HIS
HOMETOWN, VERMONT LAKE MONSTERS
THAT PLAY THERE IN BURLINGTON,
I'M SURE HE WISHES THAT KEPT UP
THEIR AFFILIATIONS AND ALL OF
THAT STUFF.
IT'S PROBABLY GOOD POLITICS FOR
HIM AT HOME.
WHAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
THAT THERE IS A FEDERAL
ANTITRUST, BECAUSE THEY AREN'T
REALLY COMPETITORS IN THE WAY
THAT COKE AND PEPSI WOULD BE
COMPETITORS.
THERE ARE ACTUALLY TOGETHER TO
MAKE A PRODUCT.
THE THREAT FROM CONGRESS HERE,
AS WE TAKE THAT AWAY, WE WILL
PUNISH YOU IF YOU DON'T OPERATE
YOUR BUSINESS THE WAY THAT WE
TELL YOU, BECAUSE THE BIPARTISAN
THING.
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCE.
WHAT YOU KNOW IN WASHINGTON IS
THAT THERE IS A NEW CONSENSUS.
WHETHER YOU ARE A SOCIALIST OR
WHETHER YOU ARE A NATIONALIST,
YOU THINK THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BE RUNNING MORE STUFF AND
TELLING PEOPLE HOW TO RUN THEIR
BUSINESSES.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE PEOPLE COMING
TOGETHER AROUND IDEAS LIKE THIS.
>> Bret: BOTTOM LINE, IS
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL GOING TO
FEEL THE PINCH?
>> THEY GET ALL THEIR FREE
STADIUMS AND THEY GET ALL OF
THEIR TAX EXEMPTIONS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
THEY WANT TO MAKE PEOPLE HAPPY,
SO THEY ARE LEAVING THIS OUT
HERE.
IT'S GETTING PUMMELED.
IN THE END, SOMETHING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN TO THESE TEAMS.
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES, BUT THEY ARE JUST GOING
TO PAT THE POLITICIANS ON THE
HAND AND SAY, WE PROMISE, WE'LL
BE VERY CAREFUL.
>> Bret: BEFORE I LET YOU GO,
WE ARE CLOSING IN ON THE IOWA
CAUCUS.
SEEMS LIKE WE ARE ABOUT WHERE WE
WERE, WHICH IS NATIONALLY BIDEN
STILL HOLDS.
BARR AND SANDERS, ONE
AND TWO.
>> OUTLOOK, JOE BIDEN IS FINE.
HE CAN LOSE IN IOWA.
HE CAN LOSE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
WHAT YOU CAN'T HAVE IS SOMEBODY
BUILD MOMENTUM AND THEN GO INTO
NEVADA.
IT CAN'T BE THAT OBAMA
PHENOMENON THAT WE SAW.
BIDEN WANTS TO BE LIKE TRUMP WAS
IN 2016 OR THE WAY